[Music]
the olympic sprinter who refused her
team's orders to go home early is
telling us more about
her ordeal she's in poland after fleeing
from her own coaches but
she's still worried about her family in
belarus as
mts tayab reports she got a dire warning
from a family member
that led her to seek protection in japan
her message is clear the belarusian
olympic sprinter christina simanuskaya
is now on the run from her own
government my
grandmother she called me and she said
me please don't come back to belarus
and that was
reason why i go to the police fearing
prison
siemens skye used google translate to
show japanese police at haneda airport
a plea for help she is now in poland on
a humanitarian visa
the 24 year old sprinter's troubles
began after she went on social media to
criticize how her team was being managed
at the games
setting off a major backlash in
belarusian state media
now i can come back to belarus because
for sure now it's so dangerous for me
i don't know when i can come back to
home it's my country
but now it's so sad that i can't come
back belarus is often described as
europe's last dictatorship
for nearly 30 years it's been led by
president alexander lukashenko
he's currently under sanctions following
a brutal crackdown on the opposition
during disputed elections last year
which triggered mass anti-government
protests
and has aggressively targeted dissidents
including those outside belarus's
borders
see atlanta tikanuskaya is the main
opposition leader who ran against
lukashenko
and now lives in exile frank via gorka
is her spokesman on one hand this is the
sign that this regime doesn't
have any boundaries and it's ready to
terrorize its
citizens all over the world and on the
other hand it's the sign of fragility
and
insecurity of the regime now
siemens sky's ordeal is eerily
reminiscent of sporting defections
during the height
of the cold war but this this is
lukashenko's war
on his own people a people who continue
to stand up to him
despite the enormous costs gail all
right mts thank you very much